Rian Johnson's deliciously twisted
whodunit knives awls is finally well out
even if you paid close attention all
throughout the hilarious caper you may
be left with some questions
we're here to lay out everything you
need to know about the ending and what
really happened to Harlan thrombi to
understand the ending of knife South's
it's important to first understand each
character in the film's sprawling cast
and how they're all connected to one
another at the top of the family tree is
Harlan's wizened mother great Onawa
Netta who doesn't say much but sees a
lot and then this Harlan and his two
surviving children Linda and Walt Walt
ostensibly runs Harlan's publishing
house Melinda is a self-made
businesswoman who built a business from
the ground up hi I'm Walt Rami and if
their name sounds familiar it's probably
because you know my dad in reality
Harlan is still the one pulling the
strings and Linda Goss says start with
the Handy million dollar startup loan
from a father of course beyond them
there's Joanie an Instagram influencer
whose husband Harlan son died 15 years
earlier she's been living off of
Harlan's generosity ever since Linda is
married to Richard and they have an
adult son you although the family calls
him by his middle name
ransom Walters married to Donna and they
have a teenage son Jacob and Joanie has
a college-age daughter Meg from a
marriage to Holland son also in the
thrombi z-- family orbits a Holland's
housekeeper Fran and his personal nurse
Martha Kabara who also became his close
friend and confidante
although the thorn bees often say they
consider Martha part of the family a
claim that's constantly undermined by
their ability to remember what country
she's from the only one she's really
close to other than Harlan is Meg
Harlan's housekeeper Fran discovers him
dead on the couch in his study covered
in blood from a knife wound to the neck
apparently self-inflicted his family had
all come into town for his 85th birthday
party the night before and they wind up
sticking around for the funeral well
reading and police investigation all
those who tenant Elliot's the
investigator assigned to the case
believes Harlan clearly killed himself
he still covers his bases by questioning
everyone
conversely renowned private investigator
Benoit Blanc suspects foul play right
from the get-go
I suspect foul play I have eliminated no
Sussman technically Blanc turns out to
be only partially rights no one killed
Harlan thrombi he really did do the deed
himself by slitting his own throats but
the actual circumstances surrounding his
death were far more complicated than
that
early on we get Marta's version of the
events have led to Harlan's death which
caused her to believe that she killed
him
after Harlan's birthday party martyr
accompanied him up to a study where they
played their nightly round of the board
game go which martyr always won and she
gave him his evening medication
occasionally Martha would follow up his
daily meds with three milligrams of
morphine which Harlan referred to as the
good stuff to help with the pain had
been suffering since a recent surgery
since it was Harlan's birthday Martha
thought he'd earned the dose of the good
stuff to help him sleep and when she
went to pick up the vial of morphine she
realized the bottles have been switched
she had already given Harlan 100
milligrams a lethal dose Marta searched
for the antagonist that would counteract
the overdose but it was missing
she tried to call 9-1-1 but Harlan
stopped her knowing the ambulance
wouldn't arrive in time and not wanting
Martha to face scrutiny that would lead
to our undocumented mother being
deported instead before the morphine
kicked in Harlan walked Martha through
an elaborate plan to keep her above
suspicion
while Martha's version of events was the
truth it wasn't the whole truth it turns
out that Harlan's grants earned ransom
had switched out the morphine with
Harlan's other meds earlier in the
evening intending for Martha to
administer overdose of morphine while
thinking it was his regular medication
however ransom failed to take into
account Martha's professional expertise
and familiarity with Harlan's evening
routine not to mention Harlan's own
tendency to be a sore loser
all of which scores has planned to go
sideways earlier in the evening after
Martha had set out all of Harlan's
medication beside the go board he beat
Harlan at the game yet again
Harlan knew she could beat him nearly
every time yet still was convinced -
each time they've played that this time
he'd finally when when MRSA when Harlan
overturned the game board sending his
medication tumbling onto the floor with
the goat pieces but Martha retrieved the
vials from the floor she didn't even
look at the labels instead relying on
her familiarity with what the bottles
contents looks like so when she gave
Harlan 100 milligrams of the drug in the
bottle a board
Fein she was actually giving him the
correct medication which means that if
hit allowed her to call the ambulance
like she'd wanted instead of taking
matters into his own hands he would have
been just fine after financially
supporting his family for years Harlan
had come to the conclusion that their
financial dependence on him wasn't doing
any of the many favors they're all grown
accustomed to the indulgent lifestyle
that Hollandsworth afforded them and I
convinced themselves that they deserved
it even though they'd done nothing to
earn it
hoping to motivate them all to go make
something of themselves Harlan had
decided to cut off their access his
fortune instead naming Martha as a sole
beneficiary
when Harlan turns up dead multiple
characters begin referring to something
called the Slayer role as a way to
circumvent Ireland's wishes and allow
his family to inherit his estate
despite his dramatic name the Slayer
rule is actually a real thing stating
that a killer cannot inherit the
property of their victim
Harlan left his entire estate to Matta
but if the family could prove that she
killed him it would void his well did
you just google there it is Google dad
what's more the Slayer rule applies to
civil not criminal law
this means a Martha wouldn't actually
have to be convicted of Harlan's death
for the thrombi to gain access to
Harlan's money or ransom us to do in
order to reclaim his inheritance is
amass enough evidence against Martha to
file a wrongful death claim a much lower
bar to clear than having to convince a
jury of a guilt the mystery of who hired
Blanc's Simmons throughout knife South's
and not even Blanc himself knows who his
employer is until the end of the film he
was hired with nothing more than an
envelope full of cash and a newspaper
clipping of Harlan's death which was
enough to pique his interest it seems
strange that someone would hire a
private investigator to dig into
Harlan's death especially since the only
person who seems to know the full
circumstances around thrombi death is
mater who has a vested interest in no
one finding out the truth
CSI KFC
it turns out that ransom was the one who
sent Blanc the cash and the newspaper
clipping hoping that he would discover
that martyr had given Harlan a lethal
dose of morphine which would trigger the
Slayer rule and prevent her from
inheriting his estate
but of course the things don't wind up
going according to ransoms plan ransom
was the only family member to learn what
Harlan was planning for his estate and
from his time as Harlan's research
assistant he also knew about the Slayer
role which led to him hatching his plan
if he could make a case for Martha
having killed Harlan and she wouldn't be
able to inherit allowing him to get the
money he felt he was owed ransom
switched to medications and Martha's
medical bag and removed the antidote
that could counteract the morphine
thinking that when Harlan died of an
overdose it would obviously point to
Mata but when Harlan slit her throat
ransom needed someone to make a more
thorough investigation which is why he
hired plunk when he realized that Harlan
didn't overdose after all a ransom
changed tactics again destroying the
autopsy records and endearing himself to
mater so that should give him his share
of the money
but when Fran attempted to blackmail him
ransom changed his plan yet again
intending to kill Fran and frame Marta
for her death instead of Harlan's since
the thrombus opted to not invite the
help to Harlan's funeral from the
housekeeper was still at home when
ransom sneaked into the house to replace
the medications hid tampered with the
Marta's medical bag Fran had never liked
to ransom and GRU immediately suspicious
that had done something Shady she
contacted her cousin in the medical
examiner's office and got a copy of the
toxicology report from Harlan's autopsy
which she didn't know how to interpret
but assumed it said something to
incriminate ransom Fran made a copy of
the reports header
storing the original in the same clock
where she hid her marijuana the stash
she sometimes shared with Martha and Meg
and sent it to ransom with the note I
know what you did along with a meeting
time in place which he intended to
confront him
Frandsen in turn send the note along to
Martha giving her a slightly later
meeting time intending for her to show
up as front died so that Martha would
get arrested for killing Fran when
ransom met Fran he attacked her and
ejected her with morphine
leaving her for dead but she's still
alive and Martha arrives and manages to
gasp out that the toxicology report was
with her stash and that's Hugh did this
despite confusing the statement
for an accusatory you did this Martha
nevertheless tries to save fun by
calling 9-1-1 and administering CPR Fran
eventually dies in the hospital leading
to ransom being arrested for her death
Blum can tell from the first instant he
meets mutter that she knows more about
Holland's death than she's letting on
due to a small spatter of blood on her
white shoes none of em are murderers
Werner when Martha finally comes clean
to blank after trying to say Fran he
thinks he has all the pieces but it
isn't until he reads a toxicology report
that blog finally realizes what happened
and who is to blame he realizes the
second he looks at it the Holland hadn't
suffered an overdose that someone must
have intentionally switched Harlan's
medications and based on the events of
the night of Holland's party he knows it
must have been ransom Paulus suspicions
may not have been enough to get ransom
convicted it turns out the martyr
tricked ransom by telling him from was
alive prompting ransom to brag to blog
that he'd gotten away with everything
but Samba knowns to ransom Martha was
lying and managed to hold off her
regurgitation reflex just long enough
for trooper Wagner to record ransoms
entire confession after spending the
entire film in a constant state of panic
Martha is able to rest easy at the end
knowing that nothing she did led to
Holland's death and that she helped the
police find the person truly responsible
for what happened to him Marta's lack of
culpability in Harlan's death means that
the thrombi family has no grounds on
which to contest Holland's well allowing
Martha to claim her entire inheritance
which consists of the publishing house
the mansion the rights to all of
Harlan's written works and sixty million
dollars we last see her sipping from a
mug that says my house my rules my
coffee first scene way back in the
opening shot of the film standing over
the rest of the thrombi family on the
mansion's balcony
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the pal so you don't miss a single one
[Music]